[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんは
テープボールというものをご存知でしょう
か
[音楽]
釣らない
まず
テープボールを知らないtiktokとか
動画とかで話題になってるんですけども
テープボールっていうのがあるんですよ
ちっちゃいの一応ここにあるんですけども
これがテープボールまぁ普通のボールです
よ普通のボールなんですけどもこれどう
やってできてるかというと後ろにあるこう
いうテープを何層にも丸めてできてるん
ですよこのテープボールですねバウンド
するんかな
なんとも言えそこそこバウンドするのね
そんなテープボールってのがあるんです
けどもテープボールのすごいところ割って
からですちょっと割ってみましょうじゃあ
早速割ってみますねありますねはい
こうやって着ると
きたか来てるのか
俺なんかがなんかテープボールだからうね
うねってなるんですよもっと切ります
すごいすごいすごいすごいすごいすごい
すごいすごいすごいすごいすごい
[音楽]
ちょっとエロいかちょっとエロくはないん
ですけどこういう感じで何層にもテープが
なっていて着ると中からグニョンと出て
くるんですよこれこれがテープボールを
切った形ですこれは水色だけでやったから
割ったら中全部水色だったんですけども
これ大量のカラーテープを使っていろんな
色を織り交ぜて
馬鹿でかいテープボールを作ってそれを
割ったらどうなるのかちょっとやってみ
たいと思います
ひょっとしたらいろんなYouTuber
とかtiktokとかやってるかもしれ
ません
ここにある部分なんて少ないですよスイカ
でさらに準備してありますいろんな人が
きっとテープボールやってると思うんです
けどもちょっと誰にも負けないぐらい
大きなテープボールをかなり時間使って
ちょっと作ってみたいと思いますだから
結構長くなると思うのよ俺の予想だとなの
で今日は1回寝て明日
頑張ります
おはようございますしっかり塗れました
もうこれね朝一からじゃないと終わんない
からてか今日1日でやろうとも思ってない
よもっと時間かかると思うんですけども
とりあえず今日は1日分頑張ってみたいと
思いますどれぐらいだったらちゃんと時間
もかかるね一番最初の層は
黄緑で作っていきたいと思います用意
スタートさあ作っていきたいと思います
まずはちっちゃいの作るとこからだな
なんか最初はもうね
あれだな俺多分下手だな最初は確か半分
ぐらいにしてチャック丸めて作るって聞い
たフィルターで剥がしながらこれをこれで
丸めていきますフィルターから剥がさ
なきゃいけないのがちょっと大変ですけど
ももう普通にでもコネコネするだけでいい
のよ最初はてかこのカラーテープのさテー
プってさ何に使うんだろうこれ用ってこと
なのかなよしどんどん巻いていきます
あ
だる最初はもうこんな大きさですよ皆さん
この大きさ覚えといてくださいこれがどう
なるのかお見せしましょう
これねちょっと
楽しいかもしれませんこれこういう地味
作業好きだからなどんどん大きくなってっ
て楽しいです
こんな単純作業をさずっとすること
あんまりないからさここ最近でなんか
すごい癒されてるわ今これ癒し効果ある
テープボール作るのちょっと楽しんでいき
たいと思います
まあ楽しいかというと楽しくない
えっ取れた
パチンてくるねこれこれ絶対パチンてくる
よこれビヨンってなったら結構だるいです
よビヨンってなんないでくださいねお願い
しますね
頼むよビヨンだけはマジでやめてね
ついちゃうからテープボールにはいだるい
たまにテープがプチって切れるとちょっと
だるいですね
[音楽]
そこに抜いて入った
楽しい気持ちもあるんですけどもさすがに
1時間単純作業はちょっとだけ
疲れてきましたがだんだん大きくなるのは
楽しいですね最初あんなに小さかったのも
この大きさかなり大きくなりました多分
もうすぐ黄緑色のテープが終わるので
だいたい1時間に1テープぐらい
消費できるかなっていう気がしました
ほんとテープボールでもと細かくいろんな
色のテープを
層にして巻いていくんですけどなぜね
[音楽]
この量なのでめっちゃ大きくなったら
細かくやんなくても絶対全部の色綺麗な層
になると思うので1ロール全部使い切る
までとりあえず丸めていきたいと思います
あ1ロールなくなりましただいぶ上手く
なった気がするぞよしできたはい最初見せ
たやつと同じぐらいの大きさですね俺馬
めっちゃ綺麗な丸ができました
さあこれを
入れます行きますよっしゃやっていくぞ
[音楽]
お願いします
2日目開始します
両手だと全然疲れと違うやばいはえーもう
こっちを何かで固定できれば2人プレイだ
なこれ多分
これだね
はい10時間経過しましたこの緑色に
テープだけとりあえず
巻き切っちゃいます
よしOKはい10時間経過しました
推奨玉ぐらいの大きさにはなりましたね
これを18ロール分まとめたらこのサイズ
になりましただんだんコツを掴んできて
ちょっとずつ早くなってきてる気がします
10時間やってまたこんだけ残ってるん
でしょ
[音楽]
柔らかいけどもなんかぎっしりみたいな
感じがあってはいなんかそこそこバウンド
もしますあとすごい重いです20時間
ぐらいにはどうなんでしょうボーリング玉
ぐらいいってるんですかね
バスケットボールとかサッカーボール
ぐらいにはなってほしいなちょっと20
時間目として頑張っていきたいと思います
俺これ地獄だよデッキ悪すぎて泣きそうな
んだけど
[音楽]
20時間経ったんですけどこのロールだけ
巻ききっちゃいます
20時間経過しました今初めてさんがい
ないので僕が代わりにちょっと状況報告
するんですけど20時間でだいたいこんな
感じです顔ぐらいというかもうボーリング
の球ぐらいで
めちゃめちゃ重いです本当に20時間で
だいたい67巻きぐらいしましたもう
めちゃめちゃ重くなってるんでもう巻くの
にもかなり時間と体力がかかっている状況
ですどんどんやっていきたいと思います
[音楽]
もうやばい24時間経過しましただいたい
こんくらいもう意味わからん大きさです
続けてやっていきます
[音楽]
はい30時間経過しましたちょっとどうせ
ならこのテープだけをやり切りましょう
30時間テープ巻き続けたらこの大きさに
なりましたもうね
バスケットボールより大きいんじゃないか
なバスケットボールくらいかなもうね重い
ずっと言えるわけにはいかないので5日間
ぐらいかけてもうみんなでローテーション
しながら30時間でこの大きさになりまし
たなんかでもねほんとテープが張り巡らさ
れてる感じがしっかりとありますねあのね
マジできついです
めっちゃ重いのよでも重いのにちょっと
持ち上げてさこうやってテープをずっと
やるからもうなんか
腕がすごいきつくてマジでただの筋トレ
ですあんなにたくさんあったテープももう
こんなに少なくなりましたちょっと体重
測ってみたいと思いますはい
あ出ましたはい
4キロ超えてますテープ4kmやばいよ
ちょっと本当にマジできついんですけど
なぜうちに今10人ぐらいスタッフいるの
で俺も含めてみんなで力を合わせて
丸めていきたいと思いますちょっとどう
やってどうやって今巻いてるか紹介し
ましょうまずもう装置作りましたみんなで
改良してこういう形になったんですけど
これで自動でなんかトイレットペーパー
出すとこみたいになってますテープ伸ばす
人とテープを巻く人に分担してひたすら後
はこれを
[音楽]
こうやってテープを巻いていくわけで
ございますこれも筋トレだよねほぼきつい
よ小さい時マジ楽だったんですけど
弾がねなんかハンドボール超えたぐらい
からなんかもう
持つのがきつくて色々改良して今こういう
形になってます
[音楽]
はい40時間経過しましたー
はい40時間
巻き続けたらこんな大きさになりました
あんな山積みだったテープももうこれだけ
しかなくてもう大きさもかなりすごいです
ねもうバスケットボールとかそんな次元で
はないもう何に例えたらいいんだろうもう
俺の顔だけよりはるかに大きいんですよ
めっちゃ重いもうね1人だと絶対できませ
ん2人でもやや苦しいぐらいなんか3人で
ずっとローテーションして作りまくって
ますちょっと重さ測ってみましょうか
測ります
[音楽]
これ6kgは絶対行きますねだいぶ重く
なってきたんですけども引き続きみんなで
頑張っていきたいと思いますでは
[音楽]
もっと行け
ちょっと待ってやばい
[音楽]
よしよしOKOKOKOKです
最初にやった山のロールは全部終わりまし
た
ただいま44時間と8分経っております
はいもう俺だけじゃ絶対無理だったもう
みんなで頑張りましたもう俺の周りの人
全員巻き込んでも
永遠に巻き続けてテープをあの山のように
なったカラーで全て使い終わりました
完成したのが
こちらですいやすごい大きさになったね
カラーテープしっかり伸ばしてはるんで
めちゃくちゃツヤツヤしてて綺麗なんです
よ体重測ってみます
[音楽]
結構行きましたね
6.3kmですもうすごい量のゴミが出
ましたしなんかすごいクリアーみたいな
感じ出してますけどもこれ
折り返しなのでさらにカラーテープ買って
もっと大きくしていこうと思います
みんなごめん
新しくテープボールが150個きました現
時点でもこの大きさなんですけどもさらに
ここから150個テープボールつけて
もっと大きくしていきたいと思います
[音楽]
やりますちなみに150個だけじゃなくて
さらに100個ぐらいテープボールがある
ので合計250個ぐらいさらに巻いていき
たいと思いますそれでは再開します
起きた待って40時間もやると効率化して
きて結構装置が
テープボールを巻き付けるという行為が
[音楽]
うまくいきません
よっしゃー
1ロール終わりました
はいというわけでここからはしばらく
早送りでお送りさせていただきます
しばらく同じ絵が続きましたただもう45
時間6時間とやっていくとねもう作業効率
がどんどん上がっていってあの早くなって
いくもののテープボールもどんどん重く
なっていくので結局きついですねもう6
時間ぐらいからもうねほんと
持ち上げるのでも一苦労みたいなでそれを
手首だけで回転させなければいけない
かなりの重労働が強いられました
テープボール色がどんどん変わっていくの
でこうなんか色変わっていく楽しみはあっ
たんですけどももうね
夏だったので結構最近気温も暑くてなんか
もうね
筋トレですマジで汗が止まんなくて重すぎ
てかなり
私はじめしゃちょー含め周りの人々全員
筋肉がパンプアップされたと思いますもう
夏の筋トレですねはいただもうみんなで
ローテーションして手を止めずにひたすら
回し続けてもうすぐ100時間ですかね
[音楽]
あきついよねでも頑張れるよな
よしよしよしあ100時間行きました
[音楽]
100時間行くと筋トレの駅ですねもう何
キロあるんでしょうただもう本当に絶対
失礼だと無理でしたねもうみんな後輩とか
全員の力を合わせて
永遠に回し続けてようやく100時間
達成しました1日でテープボール巻ける
時間なんて限られてるので100時間やる
のにだいたいね1ヶ月ぐらいかかったと
思いますその中に何層ものいろんなカラー
テープボールが
巻き巻き巻きってなってるのでちょっと
もうほんと切るのが
楽しみですね切るのもったいな100時間
だったらこんな大きさになりましたもう
スマホと比べてもやばい大きさのさ
綺麗な円じゃなくてなんか若干
楕円ぽくなってきてる気がするんですよね
だいぶ修正したんですけどもやっぱり
ちょっと偏ったりして
ちょっと
楕円ぽくなってきた時期もありましたが
なんとか修正して綺麗な丸にしてます残る
テープがあとこれだけなので引き続きやっ
ていきたいと思います
頑張ります
[音楽]
110時間45分7秒救急ですお疲れ様
でした
[音楽]
はいというわけでカラフルなテープ420
個分410ロールを1つにまとめたテープ
ボールがこちらです
[音楽]
組み立てたこれは涙出たよもうね本当に
一人では
断然無理そもそも大きくなってきてから
もう2人がかりじゃないと絶対無理だし
もうね重すぎて
持ち上がらないんですよもう本当にいつ
から始めたんだろう5月の上旬から始めて
今も7月でしょう
[音楽]
2ヶ月かかってますねテープボール作業し
てない日もあったんですけどもトータル2
ヶ月で110時間かけてこのサイズの
テープボールができました
[音楽]
どうです見た目結構ボコボコしてるところ
ありますけどなんかねテープボールによっ
てめちゃくちゃ
破きやすいやつとかあってそういう破け
やすいテーブルでコロコロしてると
ボコボコになったりしましたけどそれでも
綺麗な演技は最終的になれたのではない
でしょうか大きさが大きさがヤバすぎる
これちょっと雑に体重測ってみましょう何
キロになったんだろうないきます
[音楽]
乗せ方あってるのかなこれ
13.8km
14キロ近くありますねこれいや途中から
もう
筋トレだったのよ
めっちゃね筋肉つきましたこれさすがに
14キロコロコロ回すのはマジで後半
きつかったですね本当にもうね色んな人の
協力があってこれ完成したなって思います
今日協力してくれた皆さんありがとう
ございます
では早速テープボールのすごいところは
ここからですこれになんか包丁とかナイフ
で切り目を入れると中から今まで
積み重なってきた歴史テープボールの幕が
飛び出してくるらしいのでちょっとやって
みたいと思います実際どうなるかわからん
けどね2ヶ月分の重い
ぶち上げるぜ
[音楽]
というわけで早速110時間2ヶ月かけて
作ったテープボール切っていきたいと思い
ますか
何かあった時に
みんな
今やります
[音楽]
手伝ってくれた皆さんですありがとう
ございます本当に
感動して嗚咽してるメンバーもいますこの
人たちの他にももっといろんな人に本当に
協力していただいてここまで来ることが
できました本当にありがとうございます
[音楽]
行きます
ミュートン
うわなんか割れてきてる色がなんか
ちょっとずつ来てます
今のところちゃんとあのテープボールには
なってますが全然
勢いがない
すごいすごいすごい
怖いなんか変なことした
何が怖い
ゆっくり動いてますねこれやばいなんか
膨らんできてるけども
[音楽]
戦争できます
包丁の方がいいどう着ればいいんだこれ何
が正しいんだその後も放送で切り続けたが
ゆっくり
ゆっくり上へ伸びるだけでやったその姿は
[音楽]
それから1週間
テープボールは
伸び続け
た気持ち